Be careful what you wish for Parker
Hello Peter
Welcome back everyone it's pizza time this will be
my full spider-man no way home trailer breakdown
there's so much stuff packed into this so many
easter eggs so we'll just go through shot by
shot and i'll try to do this in a linear fashion
too just because they jump around in the timeline
of the movie during the trailer but if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's gonna be so much spider-man
stuff happening in the next couple of months it's
gonna be really good time to be a spider-man
fan but the way they're playing this opening
scene of the trailer with him and mj on the roof
it seems like it's the roof of their high school
it's happening really soon right after the events
of spider-man far from home when mysterio revealed
his identity to the world and j jonah jameson
aired that video on national television notice
that she's reading the new york post because
the daily bugle is a website in this universe
now obviously we've seen the daily bugle newspaper
in the venom let there be carnage trailer they're
using the logo from the tobey maguire movies
for the daily bugle but here this is what j
jonah jameson looks like it'll be interesting
to see what he looks like when he shows up in
the venom movie and in the morbius movie there's
a couple easter eggs in the graffiti here if you
look in the background it says steve ditko in
graffiti while she's also joking about all of
spider-man's powers i think that's also a bit of
foreshadowing for multiverse different versions
of spider-man having slightly different powers
different versions from the comics as well he uses
mechanical web shooters in the mcu also andrew
garfield used mechanical web shooters but toby
mcguire's spider-man had organic web shooters that
was one of the big differences with this character
then you see them swinging through the city and it
seems like they're having a chase with the police
that are trying to haul him in jay jonah jameson
seems like he's broadcasting 24/7 about spider-man
like it's non-stop ever since he got that mysterio
tape then a lot of you have asked if matt murdock
does show up during this interrogation scene
because this would be the place for him to show up
it's totally possible but i don't think that
anybody in the room here that we see like the
person slams the files down on the desk and you
don't see his head that's not matt murdock so
if matt murdock daredevil does show up during this
scene it's not in any of this trailer footage here
the whole idea with the drones people believing
him not believing him that he didn't kill mysterio
that tom holland said that when that video leaked
out not everyone in the world winds up believing
it some people think it's fake some people think
that it's real but regardless it just causes so
many problems throwing his personal life into
disarray in the lives of his family his friends
mj ned lee's aunt may even happy the reason mj
seems optimistic about this is probably because
she wants to be in a relationship with peter and
doesn't want to sneak around anymore but because
peter fought thanos on an alien planet lost was
killed and then brought back to life like the
events of avengers infinity war avengers end
game he's just worried about his family like
he knows how bad it can get when you see them
leaving school amidst the crowd like everybody
is just like oh my god it's spider-man and some
people hate him some people love him they just
all want a piece of him he and ned leeds walk past
this sign here devil in disguise no i don't think
that is a clue that mephisto is in the movie but
i do think that it is a clever wink in mephisto
from the one more day storyline because that's
basically the story of this movie in the comics
it was peter going to doctor strange to try and
find a way to bring aunt may back to life because
she had died during the events of civil war in
the comics when mephisto did that he combined
a couple different timelines basically erasing
knowledge of peter's identity from everyone's
memories because that also happened during their
comic book civil war erasing his marriage to mj
and effectively kind of retconing the character
because they'd taken him so far and they wanted
to soft reboot him and undo a lot of the changes
they made to his character the last couple of
years it was a very controversial comic book story
line a lot of people just absolutely hated it
the spider-man no way home adaptation of that is
him going to doctor strange to try and find a way
to make people forget that he's spider-man can
you just make it so that mysterio never doxed me
so even though mephisto was a huge part of that
in the comics i'm not expecting him to be a big
character during spider-man no way home just the
way they're pitching this they want to pin it all
on spider-man making the bad judgment call trying
to undo the past and doctor strange having a big
enough ego to think that he could pull it off
there were a lot of you that watched the trailer
and said hey doctor strange doesn't seem like
he's acting like doctor strange would normally act
why is he winking like agatha harkness like trust
me bro but multiverse edition i don't think it's
secretly mephisto pretending to be doctor strange
or anything like that the writer of the doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness movie was also the
showrunner on the loki series his name was michael
waldron he posted this image of doctor strange
winking i explained this in my last video too he
said that during doctor strange 2 which happens
right after the events of spiderman no way home
the doctor strange is supposed to be the most
powerful that he's ever been inside the mcu like
full-blown top-tier sorcerer supreme so the
idea is that he probably thinks that if he
was able to defeat thanos successfully with the
avengers that they could do just about anything
he could accomplish just about anything the
whole idea is that he's actually very similar
to tony stark's personality in the mcu both of
them had their huge blow-off during infinity
war towering egos thinking that they could do
just about anything that they put their minds to
in how many problems did that cause for tony
stark and for doctor strange at least in
the context of this trailer they're trying to
tell us that maybe he could have pulled it off
but he didn't expect spider-man to just completely
muck everything up like he didn't count on the
variable that was peter parker that's why he's
yelling stop messing with the spell so obviously
it's a very complicated spell and spider-man just
does something during it to try and mess things up
local man ruins everything there's a lot of scenes
of him inside the high school i am expecting them
to do another funny broadcast about this too so
he goes to doctor strange they don't completely
explain why the sanctum is covered in snow but
it probably has something to do with magic going
awry inside the sanctum because you see one of
the other initiates in the background shoveling
snow and putting it into a bin i love the way that
doctor strange is wearing a cold weather inspired
version of his costume like he's wearing the cloak
of levitation on top of a giant puffy coat on top
of a bunch of sweats but from a distance it still
kind of looks like his normal color scheme they've
tuned his hair just a little bit differently like
his haircut is just a little bit closer to comic
book doctor strange the streaks of gray through
his hair just a little bit more prominent there
are also a lot of you that are asking how doctor
strange got his amulet back after thanos destroyed
the last one during avengers infinity war he was
not wearing the eye of agamotto during the final
fight in avengers end game so my assumption is is
that at some point he just went back to titan and
got the remains of that and then put it back
together so he still has the amulet but he
doesn't have the time stone as far as we know they
have the joke about what do you call me oh we're
going by our made up names like during infinity
war and he says oh okay i'll call you steven
just a little joke on how awkward peter is in
these personal interactions stephen that's a
little weird but i'll allow it then they jump to
the scene of peter in the black suit the new black
and gold suit looking like he's either coming out
of stealth mode or he's in the middle of a fight
and he just landed in the middle of this but it
seems like it's inside one of the feast shelters
so we've seen the feast trucks all over the set
behind the scenes they're right out of the comics
martin lee created them in the comics you also
saw them all over the spider-man ps4 game in the
spider-man mars morales game i don't know if he's
a character during the movie but they are at least
doing the feast shelters i've already talked about
the black and gold costume the web shooters he's
using with those with the red tipped gloves seem
like they have very doctor strange magic inspired
web shooters and it does seem like he wields
magic when he's wearing this suit like doctor
strange somehow integrates his magic with
the suit giving him some enhanced abilities
you also see him wearing this black suit when he's
fighting electro so it could have some electrical
properties like the anti-shock costume but a lot
of people also been making the anti-awk references
because in the comics there's the more metallic
more iron spidery version looking of it with the
color scheme of black and gold when he fights
doctor octopus during the spider-man ps4 game
and in this trailer he definitely fights doctor
octopus there are a lot of you that have also
asked to because in this scene here where he's
wearing the black costume fighting electro
there's also this giant dust cloud so people are
like is this sandman is sandman supposed to be in
this movie too from the sam raimi spider-man films
that is always possible i'll address this too when
i talk about the people that are asking about the
lizard also possibly being in the movie is just
there so many multiverse characters showing up in
this that opens the floodgates for theory crafting
then as i said they get to the one more day
of it all where doctor strange tries to erase
memory of his identity from everyone's minds on
planet earth he takes them into the basement of
the sanctum in what looks like this really
ancient place that we've never seen before
i think this will also happen during doctor
strange's multiverse of madness just showing us
new areas of the sanctum that we've never been
to before then there's a funny scene with wong
where he tells doctor strange don't you dare try
that spell and he just winks at spider-man agatha
harkness style like trust me bro i got this a lot
of you've also asked if this is wong heading to
the events of the shang shi movie so i believe the
idea though is that shang shanxi is supposed to
take place before spider-man no way home because
if you remember spider-man far from home the last
spider-man movie took place eight months after
avengers end game like a long time after end game
at least part of spider-man no way home seems like
it takes place during the winter holidays there
may be a small time jump during the movie between
what's happening here and then what happens later
in the film but no spoilers for shangshi there's
really nothing in that movie that absolutely
confirms whether it takes place before or after
spider-man no way home the only thing i would say
is that it takes place before the events of doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness but my assumption
right now just based on the way marvel plots their
movies out is this is happening after the events
of the shangshi movie and just given the tone
of the trailer here just the way they're playing
this funny moment with all the snow all over the
sanctum i'm assuming that he's just temporarily
moving while they clean up the sanctum classic
spider-man doesn't think about the consequences
of his actions because he's still a high school
kid that's the whole idea here asking a very
simple question with a very complicated answer
like oh yeah we can totally erase memory of you
from the entire world but it will literally
do that everyone all your friends all the
avengers everybody's going to forget about you
and like i said it's a very loki style explainer
combining aspects of different universes different
timelines where things went down differently to
achieve their desired result it's the exact same
thing that mephisto did during the one more day
storyline to bring aunt may back to life combining
a couple alternate timelines but like i said again
i do not think that mephisto is responsible for
anything that's going on during spider-man no
way home and at least the way they're playing
this in the trailer they want us to think that
spider-man tampering with the spell is what causes
everything to break down in all of reality to sort
of collapse and mix together in a way that they
didn't intend notice the visual effects that they
use seem very similar to the visual effects that
were used when doctor strange went on his galactic
tour of the multiverse the ancient one sent him on
during the first doctor strange movie it's kind of
similar to them visualizing the sacred timeline
different timelines during the loki series then
a lot of you have asked what's going on with this
box that he's reaching into when doctor strange
pulls that move on him separating him into his
astral form it's the same thing that the ancient
one did to him the same thing that the ancient
one did to the hulk during avengers end game
a really quick way for doctor strange to call
time out stop what you're doing right now
there are a lot of rumors about what's going on
with this box though it'd have something to do
with the sinister six villains but the way they
cut the audio the voice over where he's like
be careful what you wish for you can't keep living
two lives i think something about the box contain
aspects of the original reality like he's somehow
trying to get back what he lost and thinks that
it's inside the box and that unleashing what's
inside the box will fix everything but classic
spider-man style that will only make things
worse so at least for a small portion of the film
you have spider-man versus doctor strange with
spider-man trying to undo what they did but doing
a really terrible job of it and doctor strange
trying to keep him from making things worse
then when he talks about the stability of space
and time sort of crumbling then just completely
messing everything up with the multiverse and
blending different realities when you see the
landscape of new york city shifting and it looks
similar to what we saw during the doctor strange
movie when it was happening during that film they
were actually manipulating dark energy to do that
so this does seem very dormammu inspired but i
think it's just meant to highlight the idea that
reality around them is crumbling and we're heading
towards a scenario towards the collapse of all
reality but things won't really get that bad until
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness and it gets
back to that loki explainer where they talk about
the collapse of all reality but that's because of
the all-out multiverse war that the kang variants
were happening it's just that in spider-man no
way home and in doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness you have similar things happening
but just in slightly different ways so it's as
if doctor strange spider-man scarlet witch and
then sylvie on the loki series are all having a
competition with each other to see who can mess up
all of creation the worst challenge accepted he
says the multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little then they use that as
the introduction for some of the sinister six
villains from the other spider-man franchises you
see electro's blast of lightning from jamie foxx's
electro it's yellow energy even though i think
it's going to be the same version of electro i
think they just tuned the character a little bit
like there are a couple minor costume changes for
some of the characters but doctor octopus for
instance has the exact same arms from the tobey
maguire films while this boss fight is happening
you notice there's a daily bugle news truck it's
the daily bugle logo from the main spider-man mcu
universe then seemingly during one of these scenes
where reality is sort of crumbling around them
doctor strange is trying to salvage everything
you see spider-man in him on the train which
i think because we have doctor octopus in this
movie is meant to be a clever wink at the train
fight from spider-man 2. when doctor strange is
telling him the problem is you trying to live
two different lives peter parker and spider-man
and trying to keep those two lives completely
separate i think what they're foreshadowing here
is that eventually peter parker will get to the
point where he can reveal his identity on his own
terms like he'll have a version of that iron man
one scene where he reveals the secret identity but
he'll be doing it himself because he wants to not
because somebody else doxed him this whole mess
with what looks like a swat team coming to take
happy end just seems like it's from earlier in
the film when they're going around rounding up all
of peter's friends and family to interrogate them
this scene of the black hand reaching out growling
trying to break past the barrier and swipe peter
a lot of people have wondered if this might
actually be lizard because there's so many
sinister six villains in the movie it could be a
version of lizard it could have something to do
with what's inside that box that he's trying
to open but we just need some more footage
to confirm so right now just open to theory
crafting about what this actually represents
like i said in my last video though i do not think
that it's venom then we get the whole bridge fight
scene with doctor octopus and he's wearing the
iron spider costume during the bridge fight scene
they intercut it with the goblin bomb and the
laugh from willem dafoe's green goblin from the
tobinguard films before doctor octopus from the
tobey maguire films attacks him saying hello peter
while he's in the iron spider suit so it sounds
like the bridge fight scene is him fighting a
couple different sinister six villains and it's
after they've teamed up in the film maybe when we
get to the next big trailer we'll see full-blown
electro and full-blown green goblin like i said
the whole idea with them coming back to life or
coming into this universe is because then blending
alternate timelines in that effectively bringing
them back to life there were a lot of you that
said that this scene of him saying hello peter and
him suiting up in the iron spider suit seem kind
of sus like is this meant to be misleading are
there other versions of spider-man in this scene
and we just don't see it because they digitally
removed it the way they altered all the infinity
war and the avengers and game trailers to make
us believe that different things were happening
i do think that they will try to intentionally
mislead us with a couple of these trailer scenes
but talk about references and easter eggs this
suit that peter is wearing the blue suit with
the jacket and the tie looks exactly like
the suit that toby maguire's spider-man war
during his movies but for the most part
i'm still expecting most of the movie to be
tom holland spider-man vs this multiverse version
of the sinister six with a little bit of help
from doctor strange and then some big tag scenes
from the other versions of spider-man like andrew
garfield spider-man toby maguire spider-man i'm
also expecting some sort of tag scene for doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness sort of setting up
what's happening with scarlet witch i don't think
that she's gonna be anywhere during this movie
they might reference what happened with the hex
just a little bit doctor strange might reference
the darkhold or something like that but a lot of
that scarlet witch stuff they won't really deal
with until the actual doctor strange two movie
and like i said also i don't think that kang is
going to be a big character during this as well
i think that they just completely muck up reality
the multiverse because of this spell and that sort
of provides the back door for the villain of
doctor strange 2 to surface before the events
of that film but while the events of this are
happening in the background of the multiverse
like you have to picture the giant infinite marvel
multiverse the kang multiverse war is busy playing
out i already talked about the Wandavision easter
egg for august 23rd a lot of people asking about
this date because on Wandavision they had it
circled with a heart around it did it predict
the trailer coming out the truth is is that it's
more of a coincidence a really cool coincidence
because originally this movie spider-man no way
home was going to come out during the summer so
we would have seen this trailer months and months
ago but this week is the anniversary of spider-man
being taken out of the mcu two years ago when sony
and marvel had their big spat so i think that's
the bigger august 23rd connection that you could
make but post all your theories in the comments
below if there any easter eggs that you spotted
that i didn't talk about during the video or
anything that i didn't address in my last couple
of videos just write it below in the comments i
will do a couple more videos about the sinister
six characters and what's going on with them
in my full marvel what if episode 3 video we'll
post next on wednesday morning so make sure you
have alerts enable so you don't miss any of that
while you wait for everything click here for my
other spiderman no way home trailer video and
click here for my brand new eternals trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!